el bolsillo de los ciudadanos en eeuu
está golpeado y por lo visto así seguirá
de acuerdo con la oficina de
estadísticas laborales de enero 2021 a
enero de 2022 la inflación alcanzó un
aumento de 7,5 por ciento el más alto de
este febrero de 1982 esta inflación es
real está perjudicando a la gente es el
75 por ciento eso es un impuesto y sigue
aumentando no está disminuyendo
las causas de la alta inflación en eeuu
responden entre otras cosas a los
problemas en la cadena de suministro la
entrega de ayudas por la pandemia y las
tasas de interés ultrabajas los mayores
incrementos se sintieron en los
alimentos la electricidad y la vivienda
desde virginia el presidente job airén
anunció su plan para combatir el
fenómeno inflacionario hoy 1 de cada 4
estadounidenses que necesita
medicamentos recetados tienen
dificultades para pagar los casi el 30
por ciento se saltó dosis de
medicamentos esenciales voy a trabajar
como el para bajar los precios de
la gasolina lo cual voy a hacer para
asegurarme de que sigamos fortaleciendo
las cadenas de suministro para reducir
el costo de energía y todos los demás
que llegan a eeuu en el senado el líder
de la minoría republicana no
desaprovechó la ocasión para atacar la
política y con
las políticas demócratas han creado una
corriente inflacionaria que está
obligando a las familias y las pequeñas
empresas a nadar lo más rápido posible
sólo para evitar ser absorbidos por el
mar
se espera que la reserva federal anuncie
un alza en las tasas de interés en marzo
para intentar estabilizar la economía